chewed an arrow into my eye we have only
one more episode of Monarch until the
season finale apologies on not having a
video for last episode apparently my
family thinks staying inside all day and
talking about TV shows is unhealthy and
I couldn't Hoshi my way out of spending
time with them but we're now back with a
whole slew of new answers and theories
to prepare us for the final episode as
always I've left time stamps below to
all the topics I'll be covering now
let's get into it it's been over 3 years
since KO fell through that Kass in
Kazakhstan presumed dead Bill and Lee
have not only taken care of her son
Hiroshi but continue her work with
project Monarch all of this has led up
to a mission to what general Pucket
calls the underspace the world under our
own where the Titans live Dr Suzuki who
we met briefly in episode 6 has found a
way to this new world however one can't
simply travel there on their own the way
is blocked by unstable energy which can
only be calmed by the presence of a
Titan thus Monarch has developed an
ingenious Solution by luring a Titan so
they can slip in along with it remember
that weird device Suzuki used to lure
Godzilla they've strapped one of these
babies to the bottom of their metallic
craft hoping to lure a Titan to
stabilize the portal then it's simply a
matter of letting their spherical craft
go and let gravity do the rest but the
test doesn't go as planned as a blast of
energy explodes topside making those in
charge including Bill Randa think that
the crew has been killed but Lee and two
others survived the crash emerging in
the home world of the Titans commonly
referred to as Hollow Earth it's
important to knowe that Lee was only
down here for a few hours before a Titan
attack opens another portal and sucks
him back to 1982 Japan want a years have
passed when it was only a few hours for
him this explains why he looks so good
for being someone who should be in his
'90s don't let this get to your head but
you look good for 90 whatever the exact
cause for this time discrepancy isn't
exactly known but the show is often
stated that the laws of physics as we
know them are different in the hollow
Earth this would also explain koo's
reappearance at the end of the episode
looking exactly the same as she did in
1959 if we're going by Lee's experience
it's possible that KO has only been here
for a few days while over 50 years have
passed topside it's also possible it
could be longer we don't know if time
can Quicken or slow down here or how it
even works frankly we do know that KO
has had enough time to Fashion her own
bow and it's Poss she is the one sending
these aamma messages from below but how
could she possibly do that well Lee and
his crew did leave behind Dr Suzuki's
gamma emitter when they came in 1962 so
it's entirely possible that KO found
this and having known how to use it by
Suzuki himself was blasting this energy
in the form of Morse code this was the
first episode where I got a bad feeling
about haroshi specifically his chat with
Lee in 1982 not only does he not want to
help Lee but but he sends him off to
this old folks home to be drugged until
he dies of old age if you put yourself
in his shoes almost everyone he's cared
about has died as a result of Monarch
and in this episode he learns that Kate
has died as well he even tells Lee that
everyone would still be alive if it
weren't for all of them meddling around
with the Titans we also know that even
though he worked for Monarch he used
their resources for his own personal
projects and was fired for it so he has
motivation to hate both the Titans and
monarchs which could mean he teams up
with Apex cybernetics which were hinted
at at the end of episode 7 apex's goal
is to destroy the Titans by controlling
them so it's a possible Avenue the show
could go down after dodging these cool
reverse lightning strikes a result of
the portals energy dispersing Lee and
may travel through the hollow Earth it's
very likely that they'll end up finding
Kate and KO which will make for a very
interesting reunion between a Lee and
his old fling Ken also awakens in a
Tokyo hospital after the collapse of the
Kazakhstan reactor at the end of episode
8 Verdugo basically tells him to get
lost and that Monarch will take things
from here but after a pep talk from his
mom he decides not to give up leading to
a confrontation with his father it's
possible we could see these two teaming
up in their search for answers the title
of this episode is Axis Mundi a Latin
term meaning axis of the world it's
basically a concept that describes a
central point in which our world or
Universe revolves and this axis can
connect different Realms or dimensions
ions the one here connects our world up
top and the hollow Earth Below now we
get into our trailer sleuthing section
where we look at The Season's trailers
to see what might be coming up well it
looks like May and Kate have reunited
and that they're talking to KO note the
Monarch capsule in the background which
suggests the gamma emitter is nearby
which Koo may have used to send those
messages with this shot here I think we
can safely say that Kate makes it back
up top and how exactly well we get this
shot of them in the Monarch capsule my
guess is that they l l a Titan over to
suck them back topside or maybe they get
some help from Monarch in this task back
up top we see these soldiers escorting
plain closed civilians are these Monarch
soldiers or perhaps Apex here we have a
shot of the loton Dragon who we were
first introduced to in episode 2 it
looks like there's going to be an epic
showdown between her and Godzilla I
wonder if it'll be Godzilla who protects
May Kate and KO as they make their
escape well that's about it for this
video now I turn it over to you what do
you you think will happen in the season
finale let me know in the comments below
thanks for watching be sure to like And
subscribe and for more bad takes you can
follow me on Twitter and Instagram at
thinkstory YT until next time remember
Daddy loves you very
much